he probably heard some of the  controversy over Justin Bieber's new  Calvin Klein ads yeah a lot of people  are saying his body was photoshopped to  appear more robust particularly in the  crotch area  there's the photograph right there let's  say it's been enhanced well yesterday  the Biebs attempted to refute those  claims by posting this photo of himself  in a towel with the caption Photoshop  lol now again I think the intent the  intention of this photo was for us to  focus on the crotch area  okay well Biebs I will concede that this  photo you took was not photoshopped it  was however cropped we got a hold of the  original take a look you'll see what  he's up to  I just think that it's not really  [Applause]  [Music]  that is that guy's jaw  [Laughter]  let's guys with Bieber 24/7 it looks  like he's trying to knock a wasp's nest  up makes two hundred thousand dollars a  year that yeah  you